how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we have some really exciting news to
talk about today because there are
reports going around that Deadpool will
be entering the MCU soon that's right
according to some reports Deadpool
coming into the MCU is now a priority
for Marvel Studios President Kevin Feige
and Marvel Studios and according to
these reports Marvel is thinking about
introducing Deadpool into the MCU in
some ways that you might not expect but
are super exciting to hear about so I'll
go ahead and break all the reports down
in this video just a heads-up to anyone
new to my channel when I reach 400,000
subscribers I will be picking three
winners and each winner will get to
choose one item from the Marvel Legends
series collection to enter you must be
subscribed to my channel hit that thumbs
up button and I'll talk more about it at
the end of the video so this report
originally comes from MCU cosmic comm
and is now being reported by other sites
such as comic book calm and the diz
insider and now that the Disney Fox deal
is done
Marvel has already announced that they
are not going to keep the actors who
play the x-men but they are of course
going to keep Ryan Reynolds as Deadpool
so it seems like according to this
report introducing Deadpool into the MCU
is somewhat of a priority for Marvel
right now and obviously the easiest
option since they're just going to stick
with Ryan Reynolds which is a no brainer
there would be just so many fans that
would be so mad if they got rid of Ryan
Reynolds as Deadpool so Marvel has
multiple ideas of ways to bring Deadpool
into the MCU and according to this
report they have three ways that they're
talking about right now one of course
would be a Deadpool solo film so
Deadpool 3 another would be to give him
his own Disney Plus series and the last
option which is huge would be to
introduce him in spider-man 3 the first
option is pretty simple you give
Deadpool his own movie and that movie
exists in the MCU the second option
giving Deadpool his own Disney Plus
series is probably the least likely of
all the options this is because Disney's
new streaming service Disney Plus is
supposed to be family-friendly so pg-13
or below now that doesn't mean this
option won't happen Deadpool can
certainly be pg-13 once upon a Deadpool
that came out over the holidays was
pg-13 and was a pretty big success and
giving Deadpool a series could be a
smooth way to introduce him
to the MCU and also explained where he's
been this whole entire time but the
third option seems to be the most
exciting option to see Deadpool get
introduced in spider-man 3 and to see
Deadpool interact with spider-man
spider-man and Deadpool have a long
history of appearing together in the
comics and those who have read the
comics really love their interactions
with each other and for those of you who
are not aware Tom Holland and Sony
signed up for three solo spider-man
movies that exist in the MCU so after
spider-man far from home there will be a
spider-man 3 and it looks like they're
looking to introduce Deadpool in that
movie it's really big news that they're
looking to get Deadpool into the MCU
because Deadpool is a direct connection
with the x-men
so Deadpool in the MCU is really the
first step into getting the x-men in the
MCU once-dead pulls in it makes it a lot
easier to get the exponent so it's
really exciting news that this is
somewhat of a priority right now for
Marvel but let me know what you think
about this news and let me know which
option you would like to see Deadpool
get introduced into the MCU with would
you like to see another solo Deadpool
movie would you like to see him get his
own series on Disney Plus or would you
like to see him appear in spider-man 3
be sure to let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below and a reminder
about my giveaway at 400,000 subscribers
I will be picking not one but three
winners and each winner will get to
choose one item from the Marvel Legends
series collection to enter you must be
subscribed to my channel hit that
notification bell like this video and
comment down below with your thoughts
and your favorite superhero or villain
as always thank you all so much for
watching we'll fluff
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
dull it took you said it cost you
everything while crying like a baby now
you're a number